[Music]
in arguments explained at news submitted
by read your books or read your books I
don't know I think it's weaker bucks I
need a read read a book [ __ ]
read a book researchers explain how your
brain works against you when you get
into an argument
oh yeah I know yeah yeah yeah I know I
hate arguing dude me too man I [ __ ]
hate that [ __ ] you know the other day
Maronna were talking on the phone and
she's having her pre-period week which
is doomsday yes that's the dooms week
right when you're like breathing and you
get in trouble exactly so so she's been
ting right and there's a lot of
negativity my just like [ __ ] mouth
breathe in watching the show and you're
just lying and you're like blank so
blank or this is bad when you breathe
and you still it happens a hundred
percent does so we were on the phone as
she was being she was venting to me
which I like it when she vents because
to me that's like gossip time yeah I
need to call you more just cos it to me
all the time cause it to me so I'll be
like dude you know what happened if
that's what happened I'm like I freaking
lost my keys in my car yeah but no you
did it you supply store for [ __ ] 30
years dude that's what it is bad I'm too
I'm too sensitive to hear gossip I want
you to gossip about other people not
about yourself
and she was like gossip but it turned
into a negative conversation and I was I
had the flu and that she was also that
and then afterwards we got the phone and
she called me back and I was like all
right well I gotta take a poops and then
hang up you know cuz she was been kind
of like a debbie downer and I picked the
phone and she goes I don't like the way
we ended that conversation and I'm like
well what happened and she was like well
because it seemed like you were being
annoyed of me and I was like well I'm
just put into perspective right now
you're pre period right now you're very
emotional I had the flu I'm sick as [ __ ]
I'm barely
link so understand that normally when
you talk gossip I'm which I'm like [ __ ]
that fool are you [ __ ] kidding me
yeah that's you ask me a hundred percent
but just give me a break right now
because I had the flu and you're kind of
being an [ __ ] to me she was like okay
because she knows that during that time
she didn't give me warnings now you know
she gives me warning she goes I'm being
emotional right now but she just goes
off but sometimes I just have to sit
there and just [ __ ] take it because
we had date week in this past week and I
had to deal with that you call it date
week date weekend so we had we had we
hung out we went to the Graham Norton
Museum in Pasadena the Northern Irish
nicker
yeah we went that and then we had date
we but I had to deal with her being kind
of like snippy at me you know for no
reason so I would like say normal [ __ ]
like it would I would know that she's
sensitive and I would take my normal
jokes I would bring it down like 80% but
even then it wasn't good enough it's
nippy smaller than snappy a little bit a
little bit below below I can't say okay
I tell you guys this cute thing where
it's cute sometimes but she's very whiny
yeah I mean she's a creaky door doors
like weird do you take your party and
then Nikki was like why do you sound
like a creaking door put some oil on
that I'm like that's such a nice way to
say like completely oh she is good cuz
she'll do that but she'll do this thing
now she goes you're being rude they just
start storming off by a cute little self
and I'm like in her overalls yeah it a
cute little overalls dude it's just
you're being rude going off you know is
that classic like a key and peele sketch
Meighan forgot your jacket what
I don't like the way you're talking she
starts walking off on my dude yeah all
the way through [ __ ] Old Town
Pasadena from Banana Republic to the
Apple Store
yeah come on you know the way you're
telling me whoa just a world I had to
come up after give her [ __ ] ten
thousand hugs and then [ __ ] calm her
down she's so good all right so thank
you for letting me vent all right you're
all go I'm drained oh this one expert is
saying how your brain just works against
you when you're having an argument with
your significant other - yeah and so the
first one says you're relying too much
on your memory so even though you think
you're a hundred percent sure that you
recalled the event exactly this guy over
here the way it happened
you're probably mistaken true and so
they're saying guilty so he was saying
the way we record experience what oh
well here if something happened in my
imagination or reality and I get upset
I'm still upset
it happened because I'm gonna act upon
it what Wow how was that right I mean
it's not right I'm not justifying at all
Oh proving the point I am proving the
point but I told myself no my memory is
not bad [ __ ] it's real well this
is what the expert says he's saying that
the way we record experience depends on
our state of mind okay I agree with that
yeah if I'm mad then it's a bad day yeah
you're right yes so if we're emotional
stress and then when something happened
then our recollections get skewed and
then as we recall it in a heightened
emotional state the brain adds even more
new color
wait what does that mean in English it's
multiple people can see the same event
in different ways depending on their
mood I got it I'm not sure if I told you
this but this is [ __ ] hilarious dude
so this actually happened recently so
meri and I tend to play fight a lot
right but Meredith has this thing where
she'd understand like if I hit you like
this you can't knock my teeth out she
doesn't understand gradients two things
in KC yeah it's like this right so for
example like back in the day this is
like the funniest thing she ever did
jackass she knows all right [ __ ] and
I'm like there's levels to this and
she's like no curse words of curse words
I was like no no no I said jackass you
called me a [ __ ] and she goes I know
Christmas like No so this is what
happened right so weird like play fight
you not 100% so where were we went to go
yet Tokyo Fried Chicken with Lynn and
Vince right so I've no lemon Vince for
like 14 15 years so we even friends for
a very long time so Lynn comes up I'm
joking around there and I go like this I
go I hit her in the forehead right
[ __ ] Muriel comes out of nowhere and
slugs my ass Wow and I'm like yo what
the [ __ ] I was like yo chels like cool
so what did i do i'm i oh you want to
play fire so i teeth they're in her
stomach but real quick right i shows you
hit me oh I'm sorry sweetie roundhouse
kicking me like crazy a mic it's getting
really awkward people in advance I'm
like cuckoo cuckoo we get the car dead
silent for like 15 is shoked me yeah I
so like Bret home right and then we're
all address you know pajamas or whatever
in fact she she's sitting in the bed and
I come up through my [ __ ] dude I'm
just be the big guy I say you're still
mad at me I give her a kiss and she goes
I can't believe you hit me in my head
knows it pulls it what what do you mean
she goes you hit me I was a hold on
second
let's recollection Stuart who first she
goes you hit me first I said where did I
hit you she was you you hit me in my
forehead I was a hold on second I hit
Lynn in her head and you slugged me and
she goes no what oh my god so she saw me
hit Lynn and she recollected as me
punching her in the face oh damn you're
relying too much I remember exactly and
so she starts cracking up laughing but I
was pissed so I literally grabbed it by
the ankles that dragged her out of my
room
the daughter [ __ ] crazy that's
exactly what that is she recollected me
hitting her in the forehead you wanted
to get with an artist oh dude I should
have been with the boring ass [ __ ]
girl dude
how did just choke you out you saw her
in Hawaii abused me she choked me at
home and then she didn't let you took
her back and then you got mad yeah you
know what we know this you know why I
like this story so much because when I
was there
everybody was caught laughing by I knew
he was mad because he all right so the
next thing here how your brain works
against you when you argue with your
significant other says your expect
you're expecting perception to be
objective so you're expecting perception
to be objective yeah so it says you know
the old don't look at me like that like
what like you think I'm an idiot I don't
look at you like that argument so that's
an example of how perceptions are also
unreliable especially under stress
because our brains are working at full
capacity or normal speed so the usual
filters are not applied you know what
the best way to do it though is to
always record your conversations and to
play it back when you're pissed who's
gonna bring out the [ __ ] down I'm
done dude I told you I wanted a vlog our
fights we didn't want to oh wow so just
so you can see how ridiculous you are
dude I bet it is super funny that's why
I'm laughing at you the whole time
there's a recording somewhere in my
house of my dad and I fighting each
other about painting my room a certain
color that I wrote that I record it just
to show how unreasonable he is and is
the funniest conversation dude it's
literally about so I wanted to pick my
room a dark blue with white trim right
and my dad said it did it work because
we're talking he says like heavy colors
shouldn't be on top of like so he wanted
to dark blue treatment or white walls
but that's what I'm saying
bro bro I can't wait to you come to my
house a second or trashy it is so check
this [ __ ] out so my dad goes no he goes
that doesn't make sense because that's a
heavy color so you shouldn't put a heavy
color on a light color
raise me and I'm like what the [ __ ] are
you saying
and he goes you cuz that your dad no no
this is my mind talking oh I didn't say
that but I was arguing with him in
Korean and it's recorded on this little
silver recorder of him talking about
dark and light colored and he goes I go
it's my you asked me what color I want
in my room let me color it is my opinion
he goes it's wrong I was like opinions
can't be wrong it's an opinion he goes
it's wrong and I had that whole
conversation recorded it's the dumbest
conversation ever about heavy and light
colors on a wall that's why you guys
should record all your conversations
that go back you'll be in tears no it'll
piss me off I'm like you're such a [ __ ]
yeah cuz we have we have cameras in our
in our home yeah and sometimes we're we
will argue in the kitchen and I know
that there's a camera there until like
the argument starts and like it just
gets bigger and then it ends and it
fizzles out and sometimes I'm like I
kind of want to rewatch you felt like
know that I'm just gonna get angry if
it's resolved it's easy to laugh at it
but if you did if you're still fighting
over the same [ __ ] it's easy to get mad
at oh yeah yeah cuz some of the [ __ ]
that I got mad at in the past it's
[ __ ] hilarious
I've liver I can still get mad at
similar things I've broken so many
iPhones because this woman dude I wish I
could have recorded those moments dude I
wish I woulda coulda recorder the moment
she called me a [ __ ] to my face I
thought it was okay that's hilarious
dude hilarious
[Music]
you